[Música]
Haití está sumido en una catástrofe
humanitaria con varios frentes violencia
de las pandillas inflación y un brote de
cólera además casi 5 millones de
personas sufren inseguridad alimentaria
en el país según el programa mundial de
alimentos de Naciones Unidas
la inflación mensual de Argentina fue
del
6,2%, Mientras que el valor interanual
alcanzó el 83%, lo que supone la mayor
alza desde 1991 el aumento de los
precios afecta particularmente al
combustible y a los alimentos
en Reino Unido tras menos de dos meses
de gobierno la primera ministra listas
destituyó a su ministro de finanzas
cuasi cuartel responsable del plan de
reforma fiscal que llevó al desplome de
la libra esterlina en medio de las
presiones de su propio partido tras
rectificó su plan y nombró a Jeremy Hunt
en la cartera
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empecemos esta edición en Haití porque
según el más reciente informe del
programa mundial de alimentos el país se
enfrenta a una catástrofe humanitaria
debido a la violencia en sus calles que
ha ocasionado que cientos de personas
sufran de escasez de alimentos y de agua
potable además un nuevo brote de cólera
pone en riesgo a la población Andrés
granadillo nos tiene los detalles
Haití al borde de una catástrofe
humanitaria Es la advertencia que lanza
este viernes el programa mundial de
alimentos de Naciones Unidas
la situación de la seguridad alimentaria
en Haití está empeorando el informe dice
que según las cifras que tenemos 4,7
millones de personas en Haití se
enfrentan a una inseguridad alimentaria
aguda de las cuales 1,8 millones se
enfrentan a niveles de emergencia de
inseguridad alimentaria
unas 19.000 personas en cité solé uno de
los barrios más pobres de Puerto
Príncipe se enfrentan a un hambre
catastrófica debido al aumento de la
violencia además unos 100.000 niños
menores de 5 años en Haití sufren de
desnutrición severa
Hace seis meses teníamos cifras más
bajas estamos viendo un aumento de
200.000 personas en situación de
inseguridad alimentaria aguda y un
aumento de medio millón de personas para
los niveles de emergencia
Hay personas clasificadas en la 5 Esta
es la peor clasificación en la escala de
5 puntos que actualizamos para calificar
la inseguridad alimentaria
Y es que hace un mes las bandas
haitianas impiden la distribución de
gasóleo y gasolina lo que paraliza a
negocios y hospitales sectores de Puerto
Príncipe están literalmente aislados por
las mafias que con barricadas impiden
que la capital se comunique con otras
ciudades del país la situación crea
escasez de productos básicos y vitales
como el agua y la gente lucha para poder
llegar a sus trabajos hace menos de una
semana el Primer Ministro Gabriel Ángel
propuso que fuerzas internacionales
ayudaran para luchar contra la
inseguridad el secretario general de la
ONU Antonio Gutiérrez pidió el
despliegue inmediato de una Fuerza
Armada especial sumado a esto el país
más pobre de América Latina se enfrenta
a un brote de cólera que hasta el
momento ha dejado 18 muertos y 32 casos
confirmados
y continuamos en nuestra región porque
en Argentina los precios continúan en
aumento según informó el Instituto
Nacional de estadística y censos en el
mes de septiembre la inflación fue del
6,2%. lo que sin embargo supone una
pequeña desaceleración respecto a la
cifra de agosto Pero por otro lado la
inflación interanual alcanzó el
83%. lo que supone el mayor incremento
desde
1991 el aumento de los precios afecta
particularmente al combustible ya
Alimentos como las verduras los aceites
y los dulces el gobierno de Alberto
Fernández prevé que la inflación cierre
el año en el 95%, y que caiga hasta el
60% en 2023 la gente se nota que cada
vez lleva menos te regatea mucho los
precios te pide precio y lo que pasa que
bueno un día vale tanto el morrón otro
lavar el doble ahora vale 1400 pesos el
kilo morrón o sea lo que valía 600 500
la verdad se está haciendo todo un
poquito al demonio y en otras partes del
continente quienes huyen justamente de
las difíciles condiciones económicas
intentan Buscar mejor vida en otras
latitudes este viernes partió una nueva
caravana de migrantes venezolanos desde
la frontera de México con Guatemala una
salida que se produce a pesar de que
Estados Unidos anunció esta semana que
deportará a México a todas las personas
que crucen clandestinamente la frontera
Sur nuestro corresponsal en
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
con toda la información
desafiando el nuevo plan de control
migratorio de los Estados Unidos miles
de venezolanos partieron en la madrugada
de este viernes desde Tapachula la
ciudad fronteriza de México con
Guatemala esta nueva caravana de
migrantes venezolanos le está pidiendo
al gobierno de Estados Unidos una
prórroga de 15 días calendario para que
no sean afectados por la medida tomada
este miércoles por el secretario de
seguridad Alejandro mayorcas de
deportarlos a cambio Estados Unidos está
ofreciendo 24.000 visas humanitarias a
venezolanos directamente con ciertas
restricciones como ingresar por aire y
también tener familiares en territorio
estadounidense Y es que hasta la fecha
de Estados Unidos había permitido la
permanencia de todos aquellos
venezolanos que tras un largo periplo
por Centroamérica y México habían
logrado cruzar ilegalmente hacia Estados
Unidos pero ahora esa permanencia será
negada y primeramente estarán deportados
hacia México luego hacia Venezuela el
país natal sobre todo porque en el año
fiscal 2022 se ha registrado un aumento
de cerca del 300% de flujo migratorio
con respecto al 2021 protagonizado por
venezolanos venezolanos que aún huyen de
su país natal por la crisis económica y
además están aprovechando la reapertura
de fronteras tras dos años de cierre por
la pandemia de Kobe 19 y quienes además
están saliendo masivamente de Colombia
el país que los acogió en masa pero que
ahora temen que se convierta en una
nueva Venezuela tras la llegada al poder
del presidente de izquierda Gustavo
Petro
y continuamos con información
relacionada con Estados Unidos porque el
ex presidente Donald Trump ha respondido
formalmente al comité que Investiga el
asalto al Capitolio y que ayer decidió
de forma unánime citarlo a declarar en
su respuesta al comité Trump insiste en
las acusaciones de fraude electoral en
las presidenciales de 2020 y no deja
claro si piensa acudir a la citación
nuestro corresponsal en Washington
Cristóbal Vázquez nos amplía
en una carta de 14 páginas el
expresidente de Donald Trump respondió a
la situación que le hizo el comité de la
cámara de representantes que investigan
lo ocurrido el 6 de enero en la carta
presenta números fotos datos de supuesta
evidencia del fraude electoral del 2020
que critica el comité por no investigar
esta acusación de fraude que no han
aceptado cortes en Estados Unidos dice
además que el comité está separando a
los estadounidenses con esta
investigación que calificó como una
cacería de brujas y una farsal
expresidente resaltó que él sí autorizó
en su momento el despliegue militar para
proteger a Washington pero que fue la
alcaldesa de esta ciudad y Nancy pelosi
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes las que devoraron todo al
pedir la guardia nacional en la carta
Trump no contestó si va a acudir a la
situación que le hace el comité para
declarar su supuesta responsabilidad en
La Toma del Capitolio pero expertos
legales dicen que es muy poco probable
de que Trump acuda a declarar sin antes
pasar por una pelea legal que puede
durar más de un año esto sin tener
Claridad y los demócratas seguirán
controlando el congreso Y es que según
las últimas encuestas Pues los
republicanos son los que van a recuperar
el control en la cámara de
representantes y si esto ocurre
seguramente Trump no tendrá que
testificar ante el congreso
vamos ahora al Reino Unido porque tras
menos de dos meses de gobierno siguiendo
la renuncia de Boris Johnson la primera
ministra listas destituyó a suministro
de finanzas coas y quarteng el
responsable del plan de la Reforma
fiscal que proponía el mayor recorte de
impuestos de los últimos 50 años la
previsión de una caída en la recaudación
provocó la pérdida de confianza de los
mercados y como consecuencia el gobierno
detrás dio marcha atrás en el plan
económico que había prometido la primera
ministra ya nombrado al conservador
moderado Jeremy Hunt como nuevo
secretario de economía hand presentará
la nueva reforma fiscal el 31 de octubre
había sido convocado desde Washington
donde asistía las reuniones del fmi Poco
después de llegar a Londres Se quedó sin
trabajo el exministro de Hacienda
confirmó en su carta de dimisión que se
le había pedido que diera un paso al
costado asumiendo la culpa por un
desastroso mini presupuesto en el que su
jefa listras había basado su campaña de
Liderazgo del partido conservador la
primera ministra se reunió con la prensa
el viernes y dijo que había tomado una
decisión difícil disfraz repitió su
mantra del crecimiento y nombró al
sucesor de quarteng le pedía Jeremy ser
el nuevo ministro de finanzas es uno de
los ministros y parlamentarios más
experimentados y respetados del gobierno
y comparte mis convicciones y ambiciones
para nuestro país presentar a su plan
fiscal a medio plazo a finales de este
mes el mini presupuesto del mes pasado
Que coincidía recortes Fiscales a la
rentas altas Pero que apenas financiaba
la medida hizo que la libra cayera en
picado posteriormente el gobierno se
retrató de esos recortes Fiscales y el
de un nuevo giro de 80 grados archivando
un recorte del impuesto de sociedades la
primera ministra se negó a responder
algunas preguntas de los periodistas y
cuando se le interrogó si se disculparía
con el partido conservador eludió la
pregunta y acortó la rueda de prensa con
la libra esterlina cayendo un 1% frente
al dólar en el transcurso del día y los
llamamientos desde dentro de su partido
para que dimita lista se está quedando
rápidamente sin margen de maniobra
cambiamos de información la empresa
petrolera francesa total energes está
inmersa en un conflicto laboral con los
trabajadores de algunas de sus
refinerías y de sus depósitos en huelga
un paro que junto al de éxon Mobile
provoca que el 30% de las gasolineras
francesas presenten escasez de
combustible Pero por otro lado total
enfrenta otro problema como ya público
el periódico lomont ahora dos ong acusan
a la petrolera de suministrar
combustible a las fuerzas aéreas de
Moscú que combaten en Ucrania la empresa
niega las acusaciones
acusación de complicidad en crímenes de
guerra el gigante petrolero francés
total Energy se encontró el viernes con
una causa judicial en la que se le acusa
de haber suministrado queroseno a las
tropas rusas en Ucrania el caso ha sido
presentado por dos ong la francesa
Darwin kleenex coalition y la ucraniana
Race of Winston acusan a total de seguir
explotando un yacimiento de gas
siberiano y de producir combustible para
las fuerzas aéreas rusas total energys
respondió calificando las acusaciones de
escandalosas y difamatorias así se lo
hizo saber al diario francés lemont
estas acusaciones contra Nuestra Empresa
que lleva a cabo sus operaciones
respetando estrictamente la política de
la Unión Europea y las sanciones
europeas en vigor son excepcionalmente
graves e infundadas Lemon ya había hecho
las mismas acusaciones en un reportaje
en agosto en septiembre total se
desprendió de su participación del 49%
en el grupo energético ruso
tierneptegatz que explota el yacimiento
de gas de ter la ministra francesa de
transición energética reconoció la
gravedad de las acusaciones
la justicia seguirá su curso ahora mismo
no conozco los entresijos de esta
demanda pero permítame ser muy claras
sería inaceptable que una empresa
francesa no respetara las sanciones y
cometiera crímenes de guerra lo que va
más allá de las sanciones
fue una de las empresas francesas que
siguieron operando en Rusia tras la
invasión de Ucrania el pasado febrero
otras de ellas el grupo alimentario
Danone anunció el viernes que iba a
poner fin a la mayor parte de sus
operaciones y continuamos con
información relacionada con la guerra en
Ucrania porque en rueda de prensa tras
el encuentro de líderes de la comunidad
de Estados independientes el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin advirtió que un
enfrentamiento entre Rusia y la otan
provocaría una catástrofe global
recordemos que la alianza atlántica ha
decidido esta semana el envío de
sistemas de defensa antiaérea a kiev
ante la escalada de la ofensiva de
moscúcheme
en cualquier caso llevar a las tropas de
la otana un choque directo con las
tropas rusas sería algo muy peligroso
que podría llevar a una catástrofe
global Espero que aquellos que están
hablando de esto tengan suficiente
sentido común como para no llegar a
tomar cualquier paso peligroso
por otro lado Putin también ha declarado
que no son necesarios más ataques a gran
escala contra Ucrania como los que lanzó
este lunes el ejército ruso sobre todo
el territorio ucraniano como respuesta a
la explosión en el puente de crimea Sin
embargo hoy las fuerzas de Moscú han
vuelto a bombardear la ciudad está por
ella Putin también anunció que el
proceso de movilización de reservistas
terminará pronto
el trabajo de movilización está llegando
a su fin justo ahora tenemos 220.000
personas movilizadas de las 300.000
anunciadas creo que en las próximas dos
semanas la movilización se habrá
complicado
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]